the cast of Roseanne is back at bears
and only we have got Roseanne Barr and
her back from the dead TD husband John
Goodman who proved the Conner family is
still got it's just good to be among
friends again all right here we go
it always felt like family when we were
working all right here we go I don't
know it's just fun the Connors are
cozying up and a new photo shoot for the
Roseanne revival and yes John Goodman's
character is back despite his death in
the series finale I don't feel so good
well duh so what can you expect they're
getting a lot of raw sex and some humor
intellectual humor are you ever sorry we
got married every second of my life
Roseanne's final season was plagued by
rumors of feuds and infighting 20 years
later the stars are older and wiser I
think our work is better to it you can't
live in the past Dan because we all have
home wives and happy life
[Applause]
roseann celebrated her 65th birthday on
set she and John are featured in the new
issue of AARP the magazine and co-star
Laurie Metcalf is back at the globe she
told us nine shows have been taped what
was the most surreal was walking back
onto the set which they recreated to to
the pillows to every to the photos on
the wall and it was a rush of feelings
[Music]